welcome to the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host paul aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man
and what does peter parker study in
school
web development hey you're having that
tom holland has just dropped a big
interview with variety that discusses
a lot of his upcoming projects including
cherry however the real cherry on top of
cherry what was the info that he dropped
on the upcoming spiderman movie
the film is set to spin the webhead into
a whole new multiverse of madness
and throughout this video we're going to
be breaking down all the ins and outs of
the updates
as well as some of the new details we
know since we last spoke
if you loved this video 3000 we'd
massively appreciate the thumbs up
and make sure you subscribe to the
channel for the biggest breakdowns on
the web
we're giving away three free copies of
the marvel phase 3 4k
box set to our subscribers but i'll talk
about how you can potentially win one at
the end of the video
okay so as mentioned earlier tom holland
dropped into variety
to shed some light on the upcoming
spider-man movie the film is one of the
most anticipated projects of the entire
year
and according to daniel rpk it's the
most expensive film that sony has ever
made
this makes a lot of sense as far from
home was the first movie that the studio
ever made to pass the billion mark and
due to its expansive cast
major multiverse moments and more we
know that it's gonna be something
special
as for what we've now learned about the
project tom holland didn't really go
massively in depth on the ins and outs
of the story but from what he said
it's going to be a massive movie the
interviewer said
can you tell us something about the
upcoming spider-man movie that you're
filming tom holland said
obviously i can't really say anything
you can tell us what happens at the end
right what's funny is like i nearly told
you then
you are so close to getting what you
want see and
i knew there was a little bit of a
spoiler man in tom holland there i knew
it
however he did go on to say and i will
stop the voice i promise
i can say that it's the most ambitious
stand-alone superhero movie ever made
you sit down read the script and see
what they're trying to do and they're
succeeding
it's really impressive i've never seen a
standalone superhero movie quite like
it and i'm just you know again that
lucky little shoe
who happens to be spiderman in it we got
a lot more shooting to do
we started before christmas and shot for
like seven weeks we stopped for the
christmas break
and then we're starting again i'm just
as excited as everyone else to see it
let alone be part of it oh no no but
anyway it sounds like it's gonna be
something special
because as we know he has worked on some
massive movies that are part of the mcu
like
civil war infinity war and of course
endgame we know that kevin feige did say
back when the project was first
announced that this would be peter
parker's end game
and this is fair to think that the
studio will be going all out with it
now when asked about andrew garfield
toby mcguire and kirsten dunst
he kind of avoided questions about them
appearing and said
it beats me i don't know if they are
they haven't told me yet
that would be something marvel would do
yeah because
they can't trust you obviously you ruin
things
but personally i do think that he knows
obviously as he's read this script
he's just been told to keep sh dumb if
he wants to keep his job
and he better bloody keep schtum now for
the rest of the video we will be
dropping some spoiler stuff so i
recommend that you check out now if you
don't want anything ruined
okay so when asked about the cliffhanger
of far from home
holland said that when we see how the
next one starts we'll be
really chuffed in case you don't know we
did report a while back that the movie
will be playing upon the one more day
storyline
in which dr strange erases from
everyone's memory that peter parker is
spider-man
according to what i've heard this then
backfires massively
and actually causes a big fracture in
the multiverse which is how the other
actors all come across
i don't know exactly when this happens
but the movie could
start off with him on the run allah john
wick's style before he heads to strange
who then resets
everyone's memories and the consequences
of that are the rest of the movie
that did sort of happen in endgame too
as the avengers tried to be smart and do
a time heist
but it brought forward a thanos that
wanted to wipe out all life in the
universe
anyway the podcast was a fun listen
especially if you're interested in
cherry
so i've linked it below or i think i
have yeah if i've forgotten
just google it please okay so as for
external stuff on the project
it's long been rumored that miles
morales will be appearing in the movie
at some point
potentially setting up his own spin-off
saga after the successive into the
spider-verse
i'm a bit unsure on this personally but
we'll go over the evidence towards it
and then what i think in general now the
character was of course teased in
spider-man homecoming
when his uncle aaron name-dropped his
nephew during an interrogation
because of the snap we know that it's
possible that he survived
and has grown five years from being a
little kid
this could indeed put him in a good
position to become another spider-man
and step under peter parker's wing or
rather web
not a good joke now the first tease
towards this comes with the feast logo
which appeared on the side of a truck on
set if you played the recent ps4 and ps5
spider-man games
then you'll know that this is a big
location that's central to the story
miles often helps there too so he could
definitely be popping in
in addition to this is the image on
screen now in which we can see
someone who looks like they could fit
the role of miles pretty well
and they're wearing a mocapsu too which
means that should the vfx artists need
to add anything over the top of it
they can do what they want however it
does look a bit swanky that doesn't it
now this means that the character could
indeed be miles or it could simply be a
stuntman that's having to play a cgi
character
zendaya did recently state in an
interview that she spent a lot of time
running from aliens
and therefore it could just be a
stuntman who's playing one of them
personally that's what i tend to lean
towards i think that the feast
connection might actually have
more to do with aunt may who as we know
was starting up some charitable
organizations in far from home
she kind of needs something to do in
these movies and feast is the perfect
place to have her oversea
however it could definitely leave room
for miles to enter
and as this person is just by themselves
rather than in a group
we can assume that he's playing a
singular character rather than
you know being part of an alien invasion
oh crap
earlier in the week tom holland also
posted an image with his younger brother
on his shoulders
with a bit of a cryptic caption if you
checked out our last video on the film
then we did go over the theories that
this could be harry osborn or an
alternate version of peter parker
but personally i think that he's just
gonna be an extra
you'll know that reconnecting with his
brother is big for tom as he's been away
from his family for a long time due to
covid
and filming this and uncharted back to
back so for the moment i don't think
that it's gonna lead into anything
massive down the line
but of course let me know if you
disagree in the comments below
now alongside this photo he posted the
caption saying
today was easily one of the highlights
of my career for those of you that were
there you know what i'm talking about
and for those that weren't you better
buckle up now this could be alluding to
the fact that he got to get paid
millions of dollars to hang out with his
little brother
on what will probably be one of the
biggest movies of the 20s
however it could also allude to what he
said on the podcast
but for the meantime we're not 100 sure
personally i think that it might even be
that he was dancing along the street
with toby maguire
as let's be honest that's what everyone
wants to see
and it would really be the peter time of
his life and
something that i think he'll never be
able to top in his career
ever again you scumbag anyway that's
everything you know since we last spoke
and hopefully that's now you fully up to
date on the film
don't forget that on the 28th of
february we're giving away three copies
of the phase three mcu 4k box set to our
subscribers
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the updates
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now
so that's you they're messaging me on
twitter at heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
our one division theories
which will be linked on screen right now
we go over who we think the big bad is
the person that's in witness protection
maria rambo returning and a lot more
without the way thanks for sitting
through the video i mean paul
i'll see you next time yeah you take
care of yourself peace